[APPLAUSE]
WILLIAM SHUNN: Thank you.
"The detective
unlocks my tiny room
and drags a plastic chair
in from the hallway.
Mr. Shunn, she says, I'd like
to ask you some questions now
if you have a few minutes.
I'm not going anywhere, I
say, narrowing my eyes--
my stinging eyes.
There's no one but the detective
and me in this consultation
booth.
No knob on the
inside of the door.
The detective locks us in,
sits down crosses her legs,
and smooths her
short, short skirt.
I squirm in my chair.
She's disconcertingly
blonde, mid 30s.
I'm 19 years old, and
I haven't been alone
so close to a woman
in five months.
With no table between us
our knees nearly touch.
This is against mission rules
in so many ways I can't even
count.
She arranges a Steno
pad atop her bare thigh,
pencil sharpened and poised.
Should I call you-- what
is it, elder, instead?
I try to breathe easy and
keep my eyes above her neck.
Either way.
Your name please, elder.
I'm confused.
You used it a minute ago.
For the record, her
green eyes don't blink.
Full name.
I touch the spot on my
sweater where the black name
tag should have been.
Donald William Shunn the second.
Age?
19.
Are you a Canadian citizen?
No, I'm American.
And you've been in
Canada for how long?
Uh, five months about.
Any previous criminal record?
No.
She takes sharp efficient
notes in shorthand,
a skill I didn't
know still existed.
OK, elder, she says, crossing
her legs the other way.
Let's talk about your
activities today.
I keep my eyes up, up.
I've been through this
already with the constable
at the airport.
She shrugs.
Now you're going
through it with me,
and you'll probably
go through it
with someone else after that.
That's how these things go.
I'd like to talk to
my mission president.
So would we, elder.
We take terrorism
very seriously.
The word knocks
the wind out of me.
What?
Terrorism.
Conspiracy.
Conspiracy?
There's no conspiracy.
She taps her pencil
against the pad.
Imagine what it
looks like from here.
I'm going to prison.
I'm going to prison, and
I'm going to die there.
I'm not a terrorist.
The words grate in my throat.
I already explained
what happened.
Explain it to me.
Help me out here.
We can't get any of your
people on the phone.
All we have is you.
All you have is you.
I close my eyes, trying
to work my frozen lungs.
How many times was Joseph
Smith in scrapes like this?
Plenty, and he got through it.
Well, no, actually they
shot him in the end,
but I try not to
think about that.
I can get through this.
Elder Shunn, tell me,
says the detective.
Tell me how you ended up here.
My impulse is to
blurt out everything.
I take a deep breath.
I choose my details with care."
That was the prologue
from my memoir,
"The Accidental
Terrorist-- Confessions
of a Reluctant Missionary."
The book tells a story of
how as a 19 year old Mormon
missionary in Canada I came
to be arrested and convicted
for felony mischief.
Before I talk a little bit
about how the book came
to be written and
published and read a couple
more short excerpts, though, I
want to offer two disclaimers.
First, though I'm no
longer a practicing Mormon
and have not been for
more than 20 years,
and though the book does delve
into some controversial aspects
of Mormon history, I'm not here
either to critique or defend
the faith, only to
offer a small glimpse
into the lives of its
mysterious, cleancut, wide eyed
young missionaries.
Second, though you'll
hear depictions today
of certain criminal
activities, I'm
not here to glamorize,
condone, or defend them.
In other words, kids,
don't try this stuff
at home or at the airport.
Now, why did I write "The
Accidental Terrorist?"
Well, fame and
fortune obviously.
I mean, why else
would anyone undertake
the spectacularly
self-destructive task
of writing a book,
especially one
that ended up taking 17
years start to finish.
Honestly I started
wanting to write
about being a missionary
almost as soon
as I became a missionary.
We probably all picture
Mormon missionaries
as an army of interchangeable
young men in white shirts
and ties trudging endlessly
from one porch to the next
with a holy book and an
urgent message from God.
Even growing up Mormon
this was pretty much how
I always envisioned mission
life would be-- holy young men
walking with the Holy
Spirit, testifying boldly,
and saving souls.
It wasn't until I turned 19 and
was pressed into service myself
that I discovered a
more colorful reality.
The missionaries I
met were anything
but homogeneous and
frequently anything but holy.
Some were diligent,
and some were slackers.
Some were pious, sure,
but more were profane.
There was gossip, and brown
nosing, and backstabbing.
A few of my colleagues
seemed to be
set on breaking every rule in
our little white handbook, not
to mention a commandment or two.
I mean, they were despite
the black name tags
really just a bunch of teenage
boys with all that implies.
Myself-- I was something of a
sheltered kid up to that point
having grown up in Utah
in a large Mormon family,
but I was also a budding
science fiction writer.
I'd attended the
Clarion Workshop
in science fiction writing
at Michigan State University
the previous summer,
so I was already
planning on a writing
career, and my reaction
to the absurd reality
of mission life
was inevitably a powerful
desire to write about it.
This desire only intensified
after the incident
that got me arrested and
expelled from Canada.
Yes, that's my actual
conviction record right there.
I was only 19, but I now
had two bizarre experiences
under my belt that few
people in the world
could claim-- Mormon mission
service abroad and a hijacking
trial.
Either one would be
interesting alone,
but together it seemed
like gold to me.
The potency of the combo came
into sharper focus for me
after I returned home
from missionary service.
My arrest had made the news not
just in Canada, but in Utah,
too.
Telling the story of
how it had all gone down
became my party trick.
In any gathering,
inevitably someone
would tell someone else that I
was the terrorist missionary,
or someone would find out
that I was no longer allowed
into Canada, and people
would crowd around,
and I'd have to tell
the story again.
I got pretty good at it and
at stretching or condensing
the narrative to fit the
attention span of the audience.
I could do it in 5 or 10
minutes, or as happened two
or three times, I could go
on for two hours or more
and not lose anyone.
I won't do that today.
Now, my primary objective
in the storytelling
was simply to
explain myself, which
I think is something
we all feel,
and which is why
this world of ours
is so filled with
books and blogs.
For me, probably as a
result of my upbringing
there is little worse
than being misunderstood,
so when someone would say to
me, you made a bomb threat?
God, how stupid could you be?
I felt compelled to
respond, yes, it was stupid,
and I wouldn't do
it again, but you
have to understand
the series of events
that made it seem
like a good choice
at the time-- the
only possible choice.
I did eventually
start writing it
all down-- first as a
series of posts on GEnie
in the early 90s.
You remember GEnie?
Then as something of a
serialized proto blog
on my website in 1995, where you
can still find that version--
and finally in 1999,
as a serious attempt
to write the definitive,
compassionate,
and massive chronicle of the
lives and culture of Mormon
missionaries--
basically the book
I wish had existed
for me to read when
I was a teenager before I
went and became a missionary
in the first place.
I won't bore you with an
account of the many drafts
this book went through over the
years, or the many near misses
when one of my many
literary agents
was convinced we
were close to getting
an offer on the manuscript,
or the screenplay version
and the time it was
optioned for one day,
or the podcast that came
out of it all in 2006,
and which is also still
available on my website.
I'll just tell you
about the day in 2014
after having waited
seven months to receive
one final heartbreaking
rejection on the manuscript
when my agent Barry Goldblatt
sat me down and said,
look, this is not advice I
would normally give a client,
but this is a good
book, and we both
know there's an
audience for it even
if no one else can see that.
It's time for you to get this
out there and then move on.
It's time for you to
self-publish this book.
My wife and I-- my very
patient and supportive wife,
I might add-- had already
discussed that very strategy,
so I was ready, or so I thought.
If only I'd known what that
would mean for the next 18
months of my life.
Let me read you another
short excerpt now-- one
of those behind the scenes
glimpses of missionary life
I've been talking about.
This takes place in
December in 1986.
"I'd been a missionary
for about three months
in the small prairie
city of Brooks, Alberta,
and though I don't
realize it, I'm
suffering from deep depression.
Our job as missionaries is
to proselytize for 70 hours
a week, but my more experienced
partner, Elder Dedman-- all us
kids were given the title elder,
which is a story in itself--
has no interest in that.
Instead of knocking
on doors, we've
been hiking, bowling, shooting
pool, watching television,
reading books-- in
short, just about
everything the missionary
handbook forbids us from doing
short of going out on dates.
I'm no fan of
proselytizing myself,
but on top of my
homesickness and resentment,
this blatant rule breaking
has made me feel frustrated,
sinful, isolated, and paranoid.
Relations between me and
the domineering Elder Dedman
are tense in the extreme.
Brother Alvarez, an assistant
to the local Mormon bishop
has noticed this and
asked Elder Dedman and me
to participate in the Christmas
program at church on Sunday--
him by giving a talk,
me by performing
a special musical number.
Sunday morning Dedman and I
arrived at church 40 minutes
before sacrament meeting.
It was the earliest we'd
been up in two weeks,
and we were two big
bundles of nerves.
We both went
straight to the dais.
Dedman flung himself down
in one of the choir seats
and buried himself in his notes.
I propped up the piano's
lid, opened the file board,
and arranged my sheet music.
There were seven or eight people
in the chapel already-- brother
Alvarez reviewing his own notes
in a seat behind the podium.
The ward clerk arranging
his roll books.
A couple of younger
teenage priesthood
holders preparing the
sacrament, and a scattering
of early arrivals--
but I figured
I could get two run throughs
in while the place was still
relatively empty.
I sat, lifted my hands, and
began the first arabesque.
The music felt right
right from the start.
Despite the
complicated arpeggios,
each finger knew
exactly where to be
at what time without
my having to think,
letting my hands roll up and
down the keys as smoothly as
if they were on wheels,
and my heart rolled right
along with them, buoyed by
the river of notes, as light
as it had been in weeks.
So consumed was I
by the music that I
didn't notice Bishop
[? Neuwirth ?] standing
at my shoulder until he spoke.
Is this what you're planning
to play for us today, elder?
He startled me so badly that
I laid down a line of clams.
I didn't turn to
look at him as I
tried to recover-- an effort
that took all my concentration.
When I was back on track, I
forced out a gruff affirmative.
The bishop leaned
in over my shoulder,
peering at the sheet music,
and crowding my right arm.
When exactly was
this piece written?
I huffed and stopped playing.
1888, I said, frostily.
The date was printed clearly
beneath the title on the sheet
music.
1888, Bishop [? Neuwirth ?]
repeated, shaking his head.
No, I'm afraid that's
not going to work.
Stunned, I turned my head.
Excuse me?
The bishop rocked back hands
clasped behind his back.
The church general
handbook is very specific,
he said, casually.
Except for certain
church approved pieces,
musical numbers performed
in sacrament meeting
must be at least 100 years old.
You'll have to play
something else.
I don't have anything else.
A disconnected panic made
my hands and my face tingle.
This is what I've
been practicing.
Then play something
from the hymn book,
he suggested in a helpful tone.
You can play hymns, right?
I groped for words.
I can accompany anything
in the hymn book,
but they're not good
piano pieces on their own.
Well then, I don't know
what we're going to do.
He sounded maddeningly
reasonable.
I've played this
100 times in church.
No one has had a
problem with it before.
He folded his arms.
If other bishops don't want
to enforce the guidelines,
that's their choice,
but that's not the way
we do things in this ward.
I hated his fussy little
moustache and his stupid tweed
jacket.
This piece of music
is 98 years old.
I could hear my
voice growing shrill.
I saw Brother Alvarez heading
our way, and Elder Dedman too.
What?
In two more years, it magically
stops being inappropriate?
Bishop [? Neuwirth ?]
squinted at me in a manner
entirely unlike Clint Eastwood.
Elder, he said
even more quietly,
I won't allow my daughter
to go on a date even one day
before she turns 16.
Why?
Because that's the guideline
the brethren have given us.
Excuse me, gentleman,
said Alvarez,
laying a hand on the
bishop's shoulder.
What seems to be the problem?
Bishop [? Neuwirth ?]
cleared his throat.
If Alvarez wore his Mormonism
like an elegant suit,
then the bishop wore his like
an accountant's green eyeshade
and sleeve garters.
I was just pointing
out to the elder
here that he can't play
music under 100 years old.
Alvarez raised an eyebrow.
Unless the bishop
gives his approval.
Bishop [? Neuwirth ?]
coughed a little.
Well-- well, yes, but I'm
not familiar with this--
he leaned over me and peered
again at the sheet music--
'da-bus-sy.' Debussy,
Alvarez said gently,
and to be honest
with you, bishop,
I was quite looking forward
to hearing this number
in sacrament meeting.
I find it entirely
peaceful and reverent.
Don't you agree?
The bishop nodded
slowly, eyes narrowed.
So there won't be a problem if
Elder Shunn plays this number?
All right, yes, I suppose
that will be fine.
Elder Dedman on the other
side of me touched my elbow.
Smoke break, he whispered?
Fighting back tears, I nodded
gratefully and stood up,
shoving my hands
into my pockets.
We'll be back in a few
minutes, Dedman said,
and I trailed him down
the steps from the dais.
When I looked back
through a watery veil
before exiting the
chapel, Brother Alvarez
was explaining
something to the bishop
quietly and furiously
very close to his ear.
In the men's room,
I wiped my eyes
and tried to still the
anger quivering in my hands.
Elder Dedman watched me in
the mirror with concern,
an emotion I hadn't imagined
was part of his repertoire.
He handed me another
dampened paper towel.
Are you going to be OK?
Yeah, I think so.
I plastered the cool
towel to my forehead
and squinted at myself.
Thanks.
Dedman leaned back against one
of the sinks, shaking his head.
Man, that guy's a jerk.
I don't care if he is a bishop.
He ought to get
punched in the nose.
Someone at least ought
to give him a swirly.
If he walked in here
right now, I'd do it, too.
Picturing Dedman forcing the
bishop's head down a toilet,
I couldn't help
but snort a little.
I don't-- I don't think
he has enough hair.
It'd work.
He combs it over.
He'd end up with
this one long twist
sticking up from over his ear.
I laughed.
Can I be the one to flush?
Be my guest.
After another
couple of minutes, I
felt composed enough to
return to the chapel.
Leaving it, I'd only
had a companion.
Now, going back with
Dedman's hand on my shoulder,
I felt like I had an ally."
And now we've reached
the polemical portion
of today's presentation.
Don't worry, it
probably won't hurt.
Despite the fact that I've
had more than 30 short stories
published-- note I said
published, not self-published--
and despite the fact that
I've been shortlisted
for the highest awards
in science fiction,
my most widely read work
by far is undoubtedly
my short essay on
proper manuscript
format for fiction writers.
So many publications
link to this page
from their submission
guidelines,
in fact, that it has appeared
at or near the top of searches
for manuscript format and
short story format for as
long as Google has existed.
By this, you might
correctly divine
that I am something of a
stickler for doing things
the right way, and
that in turn is
why I am so often tempted
to put an asterisk
next to the
self-published when I talk
about the genesis of my book.
It's true that self-publishing
doesn't carry quite the stigma
that it once did.
After the success of books
like "The Celestine Prophecy,"
"Wool," "Fifty Shades of
Grey," and many others.
In fact, this stigma
itself is probably
a fairly recent phenomenon since
authors from Laurence Sterne,
and Jane Austin, to Marcel
Proust, and Virginia Woolf all
self-published at
one time or another,
but it's also true that part of
the rap on self-published books
has to do with their
perceived quality.
And in many cases that
quality is not good,
and I'm not talking about
the words themselves here.
I'm talking about the book
as a physical or possibly
even an electronic object.
By way of analogy, I could make
a perfectly functional chair
by tipping an orange
crate on its end
and nailing on a couple of
two by fours for a back.
You could sit on it
certainly, but it probably
wouldn't be very comfortable,
and you definitely
wouldn't want to sink
into it and stay there
for several hours.
Now, not to sound
like Nick Offerman,
but with some basic
study and practice you
can probably make a pretty
decent and reasonably
comfortable chair
in your wood shop.
It may not be a Chippendale
chair or an Eames chair,
but at least you
can build something
that does its job
without calling
much attention to itself
or causing any discomfort.
It's the same thing with books.
Yes, with all the print
on demand services
available today it's easy to
rip the final white hot page
of your manuscript from the
typewriter-- metaphorically
speaking, of course-- and send
it straight to the printer,
but how disappointing
as a reader
to receive a book you've
been waiting excitedly
for only to discover that the
lines are spaced too closely
together to be read
comfortably, that the font is
a harsh sans serif,
the paragraphs
are printed in
unindented blocks,
or the margins
aren't wide enough
to give the eye any relief.
That's not a book you want to
fall into and spend hours with.
Now, I probably don't have
to sell this crowd on best
practices, but I
believe if you're
going to go to the trouble
to write and self-publish
a book you owe it to
yourself and to your audience
to educate yourself
in the standards
and tools of your trade.
In my case, this meant learning
that the golden ratio makes
for the most pleasing
dimensions of text on a page,
learning what makes for
comfortable line spacing,
learning what fonts
are considered best
for extended reading, learning
about kerning and optical
margins, learning the
meaning of verso and recto,
learning where and
when to use small caps,
learning, in fact, that
small caps are not just
regular caps in a
smaller font size,
but are, in fact,
proportioned differently.
Are you beginning to see
why this project consumed
18 months of my life?
Basically, my goal
was to produce a book
that most readers could pick up
and examine without realizing
it was self-published.
To do this I had to understand
that modern technology,
while it could enable
me to accomplish this,
could not accomplish
it in and of itself.
I needed to educate myself
in the craft of book design
and typesetting if
I was going to be
able to make that technology
do what I needed it to do,
and here I should admit
that Google probably
deserved a mention in my
book's acknowledgements
because who else
was going to show me
where to learn all this stuff?
But the physical object was
only part of the equation.
The ebook editions
needed to look good, too,
but it didn't take long
for me to figure out
that good looking output
was not a priority for any
of the conversion services
that take your Word document
and spit you back an ebook file.
I needed more control of
the process than that.
Now here I'm really going
to grab for my geek cred.
I read through the specs
for EPUB and MOBI files.
I wrote myself a
Perl script that
would parse the HTML file
exported by WordPerfect.
Yes, I still use
WordPerfect-- and I have since
even before I was a developer
there in the early '90s--
to generate the five different
flavors of ebook files
that I needed for
each of the five
major vendors through which
I planned to sell the book.
OK, that might have been
a little over the top
even for me, but it was fun.
These are just the
production issues, though.
None of this would have
mattered without a manuscript
that I was proud of and
eager for people to read,
but I didn't have
that-- not at first.
I knew my book was long,
ragged, and a little unfocused.
That was fine in a
serialized podcast
where people hear
a chapter a week
over a long period of time,
but that was not fine, not
acceptable in a book
someone would sit down
to read in a matter of days.
Most problems
related to this book
I was able to solve for myself.
Not this one.
I'd been trying unsuccessfully
to solve it for a decade
and a half, and
somehow I couldn't.
So I did the only
thing that made sense.
I hired a professional
editor, someone
I trusted implicitly to give my
manuscript the same treatment
it would have received at any
big traditional publishing
house-- or rather, probably
better treatment-- and that
made all the difference.
Part of managing a
successful project
is knowing what
you can do yourself
and what you need to outsource.
OK, this next excerpt
picks up later
the same day of the piano
debacle home at our apartment
after dark.
"Elder Dedman jumped up from the
armchair suddenly all energy.
Flip, Shunn, why are we
sitting here talking.
It's been a rotten day.
This place is
claustrophobic, and you
could use some cheering up.
I wasn't sure I wanted
to be cheered up.
What do you have in mind?
He looked around
the tiny apartment.
Well, here it is
almost Christmas,
and we're hardly in
the spirit at all.
Get your snow gear on.
I think we need a tree.
When we got in
the car, I thought
we might be heading to a
tree farm or Canadian Tire,
but Dedman drove us only five
or six blocks before parking
near the mouth of an alley.
Where are we going?
Shh.
Follow me.
He turned off the
overhead light,
exited, and closed
his door gently.
I did the same.
When he duck walked down the
alley like a suburban commando,
I mimicked him as best I could.
We kept to the muddy ruts
torn in the blanket of snow
by knobby winter tires.
To our right behind
wooden fences
lay the backs of
slumbering houses.
To our left was a chain
link fence, and behind that
a line of tall shaggy
spruces that bounded
the grounds of a grade school.
A bright gibbous
moon had just risen.
Dedman stopped
far down the alley
in a zone of relative darkness
away from any street lights.
Crouching in the weeds and
dirty snow beside the chain link
fence, he whispered, hold
it so it doesn't rattle.
Hold-- hold what?
In answer, he stood,
latched on to the fence,
and swarmed up it.
The sound was like a million
sleigh bells jingling.
I quickly hooked my gloved
fingers through the fence
and strained to hold it taut.
I expected lights to
flick on any moment
in the houses
behind us, shotguns
pumped and ready for a
Santa Claus invasion.
The fence was at
least eight feet tall.
Dedman dropped lightly
down the far side,
landing in the pristine
margin of snow between it
and the closely spaced spruces.
He motioned me up.
Your turn.
I seized the fence
with both hands
as high up as they could reach.
My boots were too big to
get a toehold in the links,
but after half a minute
of huffing and puffing
and several queasy seconds
of instability at the top,
I made it over.
I stood stock still as the
rattling of the fence faded
out, conscious of
the clear night,
the bright moonlight,
and my own visibility.
I turned toward my companion,
but he had vanished.
I pushed my way between
the two nearest trees,
their lowest boughs overlapped,
clutching at my legs.
The scent of broken pine
needles stung my nose.
Elder Dedman, I
hissed, as I emerged
into the broad
ghostly school yard.
A hand touched my shoulder.
Boo!
I yelped as Dedman materialized
from the shadows beside me.
He shushed me with a
delighted grin on his face.
Keep it down, Shunn.
You'll get us busted.
Then don't do that.
What are we doing here anyway?
Dedman pointed at
the spruce that
had concealed him which
had to be 12 feet tall.
Getting a tree.
Oh, right, because
that'll fit in our pit.
He drew his hunting knife and
raised it in front of my face.
It gleamed in the
moonlight, a wicked thing
with toothy serrations on the
spine of its six inch blade
and a hilt wrapped in raw hide.
Dedman, who always
carried it when we hiked,
called it his coyote sticker.
You just stand
guard, he ordered.
With that he sheathed the knife
and clambered into the tree.
It was the Platonic ideal
of a Christmas tree.
Its bushy boughs tapered
in a perfect cone
from the ground all
the way to its apex.
Had you draped it in tinsel
and capped it with an angel,
there would have been
no grander tree in town.
Dedman wriggled in
toward the trunk
and picked his
way up from there.
About three feet from
the top, his head
popped suddenly into view.
That's where he started sawing
at the trunk with the knife's
separated spine.
The loud rasp seemed
to carry for miles.
The teeth weren't
made for cutting wood,
and the job took forever.
At one point, I spotted a
distant police car prowling
past the front of the school.
Cops, I squealed, throwing
myself flat in the snow
and cursing the reflective
strips on the back of my parka.
The car never slowed, and
Dedman resumed his work.
After 10 minutes or so, I
heard a resoundingly crack
as Dedman snapped the trunk.
I was so fixed on watching for
trouble the tree top nearly hit
me as it shooshed to the ground.
It sounded like wind
in a wheat field.
Hoisting three feet of heavy,
prickly fir over the fence
was no simple feat,
but we managed it.
As we hustled down the
alley with our prize slung
between us, I glanced back at
the ugly gap in the tree line.
It looked to me like we'd
knocked someone's tooth out.
As far as I know, by the way,
unless the police in Brooks,
Alberta have read my book,
the murder of that tree
remains unsolved to this day.
Now let's come back
to last summer.
The book was almost done.
Every piece was
in place but one.
I still needed a cover.
We had no idea that
what we were doing
was really a cover
shoot for my memoir.
It was late summer 1987.
I was stationed with my
assigned companion Elder Bishop
in Bonners Ferry, Idaho.
After my troubles in Canada,
I had been transferred back
stateside, where I
found myself living rent
free in a small house owned by
a local Mormon farming family.
The house was a couple
of miles outside
of town in the middle of a
vast swath of wheat fields.
The Kootenai River
meandered nearby.
Occasionally a moose
would wander by
or a bald eagle
would sail overhead.
I'd been there since
May, so I'd gotten
to watch much of the
growing and harvest process.
At the end of the
season, the farmer
let us know that they
would soon be burning
the stubble of one of the
fields, which would lie fallow
the next year.
Even with advanced warning,
it was quite a shock
when Bishop and
I, returning home
in the late afternoon from
a day of proselytising,
spotted the smoke
rising and the distance.
Driving up the dirt road
between the smoldering
remnants of the fires
was a surreal experience.
It was so surreal, in fact,
that we did exactly what you'd
expect from bored kids.
We pulled over,
hopped out of the car,
and gleefully snapped
pictures of each other posing
beside the flames.
Decades passed, and though I
didn't forget about the fire,
I did forget about those photos.
It was only after playing around
with several different cover
concepts for the
book and finding them
all wanting that I
finally pulled out
my box of old mission mementos
and started sifting through it,
looking for
inspiration, and that's
when I stumbled across this.
Gold.
I knew I'd found gold.
I scanned the photo
immediately and started
working on a new cover.
This image is so perfect in my
opinion that looking back it's
hard not to feel like
Elder Bishop and I
that day more than 28 years ago
were knowingly staging a cover
shoot for my future memoir.
It's eerie, and in a
way, I believe it's true.
I believe when he picked up
that burning sheaf of wheat
that my younger self had some
inkling, or maybe some hope,
of this book that
might one day come.
Now let me offer one last
excerpt before I close.
"Between Christmas
and New Year's, I
had made a break for it.
I tried to run away
from my mission.
I hopped on a bus
bound for Calgary
and then Salt Lake City, a
journey of almost exactly 1,000
miles, but I only made it as
far as Great Falls, Montana
before a local church leader
intercepted me and convinced me
to give my mission another go.
I was transferred from Brooks
to Calgary, a much larger city
where something like 40
missionaries were stationed,
including a few
female missionaries.
My new companion, Elder Snow,
was a diligent missionary
who worked me hard,
but we also spent
plenty of time playing practical
jokes on our nearby neighbors,
Sister Roper and Sister Steed.
In fact, the rivalry
between our companionships
was escalating to
reckless levels.
On the 1st of February, a
Sunday evening, Elder Snow and I
met the sisters at a fireside,
an evening service featuring
a couple of inspirational
speakers held at a huge church
building near the
University of Calgary.
Afterward, Roper
and Steed invited
us to meet back
at their apartment
for some hot chocolate.
It was dark by then, and in
the vast expanse of Calgary,
we were miles from their pit.
The sisters set off at a good
clip in their red Cavalier,
which I tried to keep
in sight as we sped down
the wide unfamiliar streets.
Our most recent humiliation
at the sisters hands
may have been why I found
myself racing to overtake them.
It may be why Snow egged me
on to drive faster and faster.
Racing down one of Calgary's
broad thoroughfares,
I gunned the engine and pulled
abreast of the red Cavalier.
Roper and Steed taunted
us with rude gestures
and tried to shake
us by peeling off
into a maze-like neighborhood.
Were we sublimating some
instinct toward flirtation
and courtship?
Was this how Elder
Fowler and sister
Niland had found themselves
on the wrong footing?
A good 10 minutes
later, Snow and I
found ourselves stopped behind
the sisters in a left turn lane
a few blocks from
their apartment.
The light was red.
Red light, green
light, Snow shouted.
Giddily, I jammed the
gear shift into park.
Snow was already out his door.
I pounded on Roper's window
while Snow rousted Steed.
Red light, green
light, we cried.
Red light, green light!
Within moments, all four of
us were running figure eights
around the two cars waving
our arms and whooping it up.
When the light turned green,
Snow gave me a diabolical look
and jerked his chin
at the sister's car.
I understood instantly.
Without a word, the two of
us hopped into their car,
slammed the doors,
and squealed away.
Roper and Steed,
in the few moments
I could still see
them in the rear view
mirror, gaped after us.
Ha, I shouted.
Take that!
Four or five blocks later, we
parked behind their apartment
building and got out of
the car to wait for them.
We waited, and we
waited, and we waited.
We were pacing with
worry, breath steaming
in the cold night air when our
blue Cavalier finally careened
into the parking lot
and screeched to a halt.
Nearly 20 minutes had passed.
The sisters, white
faced and breathless,
scrambled out the doors
and ran straight toward us.
Sister Roper grabbed
Snow by the lapels.
Oh my lord, she babbled.
Oh my lord, oh my
lord, we're getting
sent home-- all of us-- we're
getting sent home for sure.
Oh, I can't believe it.
We're going to be
in so much trouble.
So much trouble.
Hey, hey, slow down, said
Snow, extricating himself
from her grip.
What the shazz happened?
Oh my word, it was a
nightmare is what it is.
We got stopped by the police,
thank you, said Sister Steed.
I felt a stab of fear.
The police?
Snow folded his arms
and drew himself erect.
What did you two do?
He was trying to
project authority,
but I could tell he was rattled.
What did we do?
Said Roper, flapping
her arms in dismay.
We took off after you.
That's what we did, but
there was this pedestrian
crossing on the next block.
I was all mixed up and the
light started flashing yellow,
but it was too
late for me to stop
so I went through the crosswalk,
but there was a car behind us
back at the red light, and
it turned out to be a cop,
and he flipped his lights
right on and pulled us over.
Snow was shaking his head.
Oh, doper, you
got to be kidding.
A pedestrian crossing?
That is one serious ticket.
You're telling me, said Roper,
her face a mask of desperation,
but it gets even better.
When the cop asked to
see my driver's license,
guess where it was?
Where?
I asked.
In your pit?
She whacked my shoulder.
No, you idiot.
It was in my purse
on the front seat
of the car, the car
you were driving.
I clapped a hand to my forehead.
Oh no, Roper, I am so sorry.
The look she gave me would
have pulverized granite.
Tell me that tomorrow when I
have to take my license down
to the police station.
I'll be lucky if I
don't get arrested.
I'm lucky I'm not
in jail right now.
At least we had your
registration, said Steed.
That helped.
Of course, the officer took
down the address, which
is the mission
office, so guess who's
getting a visit from the police
first thing in the morning.
Oh shazz, Snow moaned,
clutching his hair.
Like I told you, Roper
said, tomorrow that cop's
going to tell President Tuttle
I ran a light without a license
in your car, and
you think he's going
to believe us when we say
there's nothing funny going on.
I'm telling you we're
all getting sent home.
My father is going
to be so cheesed off,
said Snow, eyes closed,
fists clenched at his sides.
Flip.
Flip!
I couldn't stop shaking my head,
seeing all my hard won progress
evaporate.
What was wrong with me?
Why did I always
have to be so stupid?
But at the same time,
I felt the stirring
of a tiny mutinous hope.
Might we really get sent home?
Roper and Steed exchanged a
look, their mouths trembled,
and suddenly they both
cracked up laughing.
Steed doubled over and Roper
had to lean against her
to keep from falling down.
Huh?
Hey, what is this?
Snow demanded.
What the shazz is going on?
Oh boy, elders, said Roper,
pounding Steed on the shoulder.
We really had you going.
Steed held her heaving stomach.
You ate it up-- every bite.
You two looked so terrified
I almost peed myself.
Wait, you didn't
get pulled over?
We did get pulled over,
said Roper, wiping her eyes,
but we only got a warning.
The cops said the fire
drill was kind of cute,
but when we ran the light he had
to make sure we weren't drunk.
She and Steed dissolved in
fresh peals of laughter.
Pretty soon I was laughing,
too, and after a few minutes,
even Snow cooled down.
Hot chocolate around the
sister's kitchen table
went a long way toward
repairing the breach.
As we were rinsing
our mugs, Sister Roper
said to me in her
most serious tone,
don't you ever forget what we've
all been through, Elder Shunn.
You need to write a book
someday and put all this down
for posterity.
People need to know what it's
really like to be missionaries
and how we got through it.
You hear me, Elder Shunn?
I expect to see
that book someday.
I promised her she
would, though I couldn't
imagine how to
write an honest book
and still show my
face at church.
It was less than a month
later that I'd find myself
behind bars for real.
No practical joke.
Now, 29 years later, with
the book actually here,
it feels less like I've kept
a promise to Sister Roper
than that I've kept
a promise to myself."
Thanks for listening.
[APPLAUSE]
And there's still
several minutes
left for questions if anyone
has anything they'd like to ask.
There's microphones
at both sides of the a
AUDIENCE: So it sounds
like you went through a lot
to figure out how to actually
do the self-publishing properly.
Have you thought about-- did
you write about that, or share
that, or have you thought about
going into business doing that
possibly?
WILLIAM SHUNN: That's
a really good idea.
I've actually given some
thought to offering workshops
in creating ebooks.
I haven't really written much
about it yet, but I do plan to.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
WILLIAM SHUNN: Very good idea.
Thank you.
Any other questions?
All right.
Thank you very much
for coming out.
There's copies of the
book available right
over there on your way out.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]